the Nazis were there they were taking
valuable possessions including the gold
of Jewish people right if they had their
gold stored in Germany that would be a
big problem are they comfortable fleeing
yeah but what if they had their balls
stored in Switzerland and they just had
a digital well they said it was still it
was it doesn't matter I know okay we're
in Germany and that and that's bad right
so when they want to flee and go to
another country how on Earth are they
going to do that how are they going to
do it well now though you don't have to
do that exactly because we have Bitcoin
no you have here so we can't believe